what you're doing cat I am lighting up
some candles I am so sorry I've been
buying Brendon a bunch of pastries for
his birthday this week yeah so sorry to
your diet
I know you're carnivore well that's how
it goes
tell girls that's gone that's calm hope
it doesn't burn out
I guess what's just seen one happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
happy
[Applause]
you're 37 happy [ __ ] birthday whiskey
and all
[Laughter]
you're the best I am so sorry to your
diet I know this week said to be hell
all right when I went to my friend your
sis wedding I had to get suited for a
tux Brennan where'd I go
black tux did you know I meant something
right with with freaking cork teen right
now do you just get your friends
together put on a top put on top do you
feel instantly better but you'll forget
about the horrible world right now right
we're tux but if you got a high high ass
you got broad shoulders a tapered waist
and very much go thigh that thighs you
need I can't just fit in a knee tucks
I'm built like a frog I'm an athlete as
you know as you understand I need I need
a custom-fit tux dude I'm not just your
regular guy you know so if you got a
sexy body if you got a fat body if you
got a skinny body get a tux that makes
you look good have it tailored bring it
right to your house great to you man
yep just pick a stout the bat the black
tux calm request a free home try on so
you can feel the fit and quality before
you commit to this thing and if I'm
lying in your style black tux has shelf
rooms all over the country they do maybe
you can go ahead or you can rent it
either way man but it's very very quick
just like a penguin that's why your
weddings before too so you can send it
back you said it dude if you want your
wedding to be remembered for the right
reasons or to your suit over tuxedo at
the black tux calm and enjoy temps
enough with the code TF 80k that's a
black tux dot-com a black stuff uh black
tux tu x.com Cote fat K for 10% off your
purchase
that's the black tux formal wear for the
moment well Brandon look at my hair now
you make fun of it but without losing
dude people are losing their minds
they're losing their hair I can't help
your mind I can help your anxiety with
Corona I can help your hair 66% of men
start to lose their hair by the age of
35 and once you start losing your hair a
lot of times it can be too late but what
you can do is you can basically start
moving it backwards even with ball
spots what you can do is you take
finasteride which is what they have it's
a scientifically proven pill I've been
taking it for a long time I am a
customer of hims and some blokes memo I
look maybe not but ever a man forums
calm a one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care sexual illness for the bros alright
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements [ __ ] prescription
solutions backed by science don't go the
doctor and doctor anymore it's not
awkward and so a few quick questions a
doc will review and then they send it
straight to your door
it's embarrassing to go to a doctor and
tell them hey I can't get my dick up or
something like I gotta I'm losing my
hair now you can just go you can
literally do this all online yep send a
picture to a real doctor yep and and
then you'll get your prescription in the
mail and it just shows up in a sort of
unmarked pop em and you just can start
the first month free go-to for hims calm
/fa TK that's for hims calm /fa TK give
them the disclaimer calendar scripture
requires an online consultation where
the physician will determine if a
prescription is appropriate offer valid
only if prescribed three month minimum
subscription additional restrictions
apply see website for full details and
important safety information by the way
done it very quick very easy room for
hims calm /fa TK all right listen up I
feel sick I did some research on the
kovat 19 buddy
oh yeah we're fine the flus got an RD
like a contagion number of 1 to 1.5
meaning you're gonna infect 1 to 1.5
people I guess the coronavirus has an RD
of my buddy Matt Staggs who he used to
be used to work in bio medical research
ok and and it has an article 3 ok so
that means you it's a very contagious
thing now I guess this whole quarantine
thing is to get a jump on it so we don't
run out of beds and respirator a people
will die like like Italy yes because
when you compare Italy and this is all
bro science but it's also facts also if
you look it up if you look at Italy they
went I will be fine won't need a
quarantine and Jerry went you know what
what's the worst case fishing the
quarantine
yeah Germany fine Italy chaos yeah so
that's all we're doing I've been very
critical of it and because I feel like
they're clear playing the American
on me and I know people who come handy
on my dick yeah but um at the same time
there is something to be said about so
so in Italy in 99 percent of the deaths
according to Bloomberg News 99 percent
of the death are of older people who had
underlying illnesses usually I think it
was like uh 70 percent worth they had
three underlying illnesses like heart
disease diabetes are gonna die anyway
let's be real if they got the flu if
they get it's very dangerous for people
who have these conditions it all is yeah
so is the flute the flute yeah influenza
kills I can't wait to see I can't wait
to see all our all our current events on
this you you know I you know I was
getting go to Austin still even though
my shows were canceled and go there and
shoot stuff for on it in Showtime yep we
had a food truck lineup with Tim Kennedy
I will go up thus more like it just
doesn't seem smart in our because dude
here's the problem everything shut down
here he was come out come out in three
weeks too good to be it should be
different yeah now that you probably
right
you're probably right look you know um
that's what it is did the shows for
April are for sure canceled everybody uh
yeah so I miss can March April May and
then I think I think June we're gonna
pick up well so I think that the Denver
Comedy Works I I'm the first act back as
of now their their clothes to the
weekend May 14th something like that act
well yeah I'm supposed to be in New York
May 7th 8th and 9th the Gramercy Theater
I don't know Papa yeah I don't I think I
think May is gonna be shut down too cuz
you gotta remember too the economy's
thinking such a hit and people can't get
paid yeah so to ask them to come in buy
tickets to of III think I think we'll be
back in full swing dick swinging nuts
dragon July July yeah and July August
especially you know I'm going to Israel
in July July secondly the twelfth with
my kids oh really yeah why you're not
Jewish no but my dad's turning 18 he
wanted to go to Israel that's what you
do Israel when your dad's 80 he's Andy
well this is my thing I was watching the
Biden and Bernie yeah debate I'm
brilliant for whatever reason really
into him and I watch the debates like to
him you know debate this stuff and kind
of roast each other basically
and I'm looking at Biden he's 82 years
old right and I go hold on if you did
let's say you're selected pradhans 82 82
[ __ ] is that true I'm looking look that
out look at that old well but it's the
old sorry so alright no this sorry I'm a
little drunk birthday whatever horrible
birthday brother but here's the thing I
can't do anything doughnuts were great
cow cake
here's the thing go so he's 77 so he
does for year so be 81 and we get that
81 years old when I say back nine he
didn't have a lot of living left to do
because he's not like you know ii-in in
the year 2020 and you're 77 you're not
living what the average ages of death is
what what's the average age now hey is
it 81 I think it's I thought it was 77
actually I mean he's right there done
and you want that get making decisions
yeah and he's already [ __ ] you know
mashed potato brains like he misses a
lot of [ __ ] it's like me being president
mr. pronouncing names calls his sister's
wife they got [ __ ] yeah he's gonna
pair up with Michelle Obama try and pair
up is that what he's gonna do why I
don't this is Michelle Obama qualified
to be like if that's just a nostalgia I
like her more than [ __ ] Mike Pence
yeah but that's a nostalgia vote I don't
know I bet she's nowhere they gotta do
something cuz I'm Tony homeboy ain't
gonna beat Trump by himself he's
probably not gonna be Trump by himself
no way you got a pair up with Michelle
yeah Trump is just too funny man he just
does [ __ ] I don't know but he has a
chance yeah but if you listen for all
those people with birthdays in March and
April I feel your pain it's probably the
worst time I had a surprise birthday
party I just found out this morning they
supposed to be you ready Leah I had it
off via veneto we were gonna surprise
you tonight at the event it to me Rogan
D'Elia my guy's great yeah Feldman had
it was gonna be great and and I had to I
still tried to do it what I was gonna do
was have a chef come to your house yeah
and cook and then everybody meet you
after the podcast let me cool but I but
the chef that I know is out of town my
buddy Comte but I still think we should
do something tonight for you yeah I
actually do I'll go buy some very
expensive wine
why not me you Rogen have Fellman come
over we can still do it D'Elia it'd be
fun yeah everything was just still do it
and ask all past coping around yeah
whatever I'm not worried about it me
neither
I mean you I it's your birthday and
everybody has the time so IIIi think we
should do it tonight that's what my
that's my feeling
it's gear if you don't want to do it
your I can tell you're already late I'm
not lazy I feel sick because I've been
on my strict diet and I eat two of those
doughnuts and I washed it down with
whiskey and I have a quad shot americano
it's my sick in the day yeah you know
you have you take yep
that's your first meal yeah I fast all
morning mmm it's my first meal so it's
pretty hard yeah yeah you're bully boy
you're bully boy strong boy I'm not Matt
those shoes dude not bad right my golden
goose walked into a consignment store
for no reason because I was bored
come on I went these fit very well and
buying them I like myself some golden
goose I love golden goose my my bro bro
my brother short guys doll smash out a
big dick Jay he the biggest fattest here
you've seen it it's impossible and it's
black even stevie blue eyes yeah Jay has
a black it's very okay his dad his dick
is is blonde looks 50 shades of purple
yeah it's very it's like it's like
different people's like you see his skin
he's kind of pale skinny at least got it
kind of pale skin and this here can i
well that's a black dick it's impossible
black a heavy piece a heaviest it's like
an elephant crazy girl happy
anyway heavy had a gun and a very good
body yeah leaner the meeting with the
shirt off you go you got a he's a thick
Calvin Klein model now the face he's you
know well we can talk right we can talk
we can talk right that's all but but his
oh no no devil head right there that
devil head cuz he's his face so Tim he's
the devil right there you know he's he's
he's but it's oh he's you know he's got
he's got a baby like the first Tommy
goes nice Todd yeah
when you got the body you go whoa the
body and you see his face you go okay
you know I mean it is there it's there
he's got the easy got a regular face got
a regular he's regular guy regular face
his girls a [ __ ] dime piece you know
you know she's a quarter Japanese she's
gorgeous I think Alice day is gorgeous I
just they would have had a [ __ ] kid
maybe they make great kids um J you know
because nobody's going to work so J job
just driving around this gt3 filming
stuff for himself like you're so bored
us washing his car the best but I miss I
miss him I wish I was guys hang out with
him every day yeah there's a chance I
hopefully doesn't care if I say this but
there's a chance he could move to him
and his wife can move to San Francisco
really I know I was like dude he's only
lived in Deborah's entire life me that's
us
that's me but such [ __ ] a thousand
years ago man who the [ __ ] is that how
is that me and what's with my beard and
what's that shirt I'm wearing that's all
a disaster no I don't mind the outfit
and remember we got the leaky cat
remember we got the shoes from Gucci
that you never will write a memo yeah I
tried him off yeah I got a surefire dogs
[ __ ] fire fire I was wearing my those
are common projects I look cute there
but I got a I got a die my beard
obviously chin Chin's bigger than
everyone in that picture I'm closer to
the camera she was making gave shiny my
dad my brother looked the best Brian
look like [ __ ] but my point was oh so my
brother was gay I can always depend on
him give me a cool you because we like
the same [ __ ] clothes and fashion and
shoes and he got me the Safari dunks
which I've wanted forever
Elite Nike Dunk shoe you bring him up
Jim no big deal where are they
just type in Nike Safari I thought you
were got me these but where he got them
they shut down the shipping because they
don't want to pass Corona
so now Papa got didn't get a birthday
gift that's them right there they're so
[ __ ] fresh yeah good guy yeah yeah
not for you dude you're too old not for
you and they're in the colorful yeah see
you like color
you know I like I like cool shoes man I
don't like the plain Jane's nice f
climbing rope on them for god sakes ah
what does cost what are these ones what
does regular suffice to climb strokes
cost all those the beats bet these are
gonna run you're looking for a pair no
but I bought cuz they're sneakers right
we'll just climb the rope but let's just
yeah these are off white dunker pretty
tough to get sure I mean I don't know
3000 pairs gotcha
what they cost I don't know six Hyundai
okay how much were those going gooses
you know why are we hundo I bought it
for 380 there you go but in if you
bought them if you brought these in the
store they would be 600 680 so contactor
so go
I remember my buddy Chris Mazzilli who
owns the Gotham comedy club in New York
and Chris from day one Italian
old-school always dressed to the nines
never without a suit Rolex and my
favorite is I was like you dress he goes
to dress like a gentleman you dress like
a gentleman you treated like a gentleman
I walk in I got $10,000 in my body
people know I'm not [ __ ] around it's
not like oh yeah $10,000 on your body
people know you're not [ __ ] around
he's not lying to you Chris
yes so Jays gifts come super late least
my dad remember my birthday this year
oh there you're there are your shoes
there have all three of those yep all
three bottles with Chris has to Chris
don't have the red and Grace
huh the the UNLV the Michigan stay in
Michigan
now some people leave that terrible tag
on there too I know Chris left his tag
on for a while it's a real [ __ ] boy move
look I'm already kind of funky boyish
but that will leaving the tag on it's
just it's rare I do that ah it's just
too Bucky yeah there are some [ __ ] boys
out there would you consider yourself a
[ __ ] boy I guess I don't think so those
would use to [ __ ] Oh different kind of
[ __ ] boy how about a sock boys no [ __ ]
boy you know the guy but you're lucky
you're lucky he's still kind of
relatively young kind of hot and girls
would use you as a [ __ ] boy like they go
I don't want to relationship I just want
to [ __ ] that guy ya know yeah
I'm a bill boy I'm a bill boy you gonna
pay the bills
bill Mays yeah I'm a Bill Maher bill man
yeah so that man oh you got we you bomb
a sugar daddy I'm getting to a point
where I'm sugar daddy oh girl you've
been sugar that eve long time yeah at
least alone with damn you have ten years
yeah
ten years oh do if you're 42 I think I
think when you open their 50s you're
sure everybody is ooh and your date like
young chicks your sugar daddy yeah oh
yeah as you get older I'd say I'd say 40
let's go 45 yeah 45 but I think sugar
daddy is I always think of an older guy
crane I'm gray I'm getting gray you know
it's wonderful I think some girls bills
am I still your you know I am good guy
well you're also you're always hot yeah
baby bill heard you got your prime your
prime marriage material but you're
already you're already hitched up if you
were 37 it would be there'd be a large
group contingent of viable bachelorettes
looking to get pregnant by you that's a
lot of girls want that want that that
crazy strong genetics sure they want
that you know they want to they want to
bully boy themselves they want they want
a couple thick kids
speaking of bully boys you should see
Boston right now this dude needs to go
on a diet
he's thick as [ __ ] he's already sitting
up yeah he's 15 weeks now he's sitting
up he's thick as [ __ ]
well Joe's johannah's family they've got
great genetics join Ahmad Ahmad yeah her
mom's ridiculous yeah so I don't know
man I mean it's all good you uh your
bullet boy yeah bring it up Jim what was
this thing you do with Joey Diaz I
didn't see that go back that yeah
Oh with Joey Diaz yeah I'll go to the
video chat it's a show for complex and
goalie alpha you go
Carrie if my garlic shrimp I will can go
back there and do the ten years because
they came straight from the moms of I
got a story for you that's all hey soos
Trejo's my boys a new show on first we
feast Graflex tacos : a good guy man the
best I like that girl on the road
together was a great college was
especial on Showtime
he's the best yep Fran yeah he was great
dude drives to his story how he farted
when he was in line at the DMV oh I was
laughing so hard he said there's some
Russian guy behind him he put a tweet on
it like a dude your tweet was solaris
they told me the story so he was sitting
in line at DMV and he's there for like
two hours he was he was in heels and I
[ __ ] got garlic that night and he was
a garlic the night before he was I'm
[ __ ] sittin in line he says my full
name is I'm sitting in line Brendan chop
because I'm sitting there I got a fart
and I can feel it
all night it's been said I can feel like
Tata garlic news there's a Russian
behind me I thought [ __ ] it knows I fart
it's one of those thick thick fog heart
big guns use that Russian that is in
[ __ ] Chernobyl the line it move for
for Albert's absolute Attalus because he
is we sat in this fart [ __ ] the [ __ ]
next person I won't came the Java way
but he talks about farting on a plane oh
my god I was dying
really oh my goood oh I'll tell you joy
Diaz because they use that Russian
thought is [ __ ] should know buh-bah
food Nick I don't want to give it away
cuz it's so [ __ ] funny
Oh what were we talking about kovat 19
the UFC's in trouble cuz they're not
able to [ __ ] put up their nights I
don't know why it's adamant about it bad
well they're gonna be in Thai in [ __ ]
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia do it do what
you got to do Cova doesn't doesn't grow
in that kind of weather do we do we know
so that it's going forward khabib
Ferguson she's not gonna go forward you
have location
Wow this is not Monday it's true
depression will do things power to
preserve the highly anticipated title
fight with Tony Ferguson we'll see the
chip seven together dinner's going to
send its location yeah I don't know we
definitely know sent New York right the
hotbed for he already said for sure
that's not gonna be in New York Barclays
they're gonna have to go across seas
yeah I can imagine them doing it like
UAE yeah yeah do they have problems out
there I know we heard of any case in
Saudi Arabia Middle East the stuff it's
everywhere never heard anything of a lot
of so a lot of likes of northern Italy
the reason there were a lot of like
those cases apparently is that the port
of Genoa does a lot of trade with China
of course so a lot of the Chinese
brought it over dotted the yes there are
few cases in there so I think you're
gonna see China I think you're gonna see
China because they do things very very
quickly without any anybody say so these
wet markets are gonna go away they're
gonna figure out ways to stop this [ __ ]
because they're gonna realize they have
a major problem
not to mention the fact that it's
created a lot of anti China sent that's
an Asian and and not only got a little
house you sure walk to the marketplace
now like yeah yeah a likely-looking mean
to kind of go the way Career Center
really raised done an amazing job of
containing of continually I guess the
Chinese have done a great job now yeah
back Rowland yeah but at the end of the
day I think that this could very well
get a great deal of anti-chinese sort of
economic policies in place where people
like well I don't want to be this
dependent on China do you know that
something like 85 90 percent of our
medicine is made in China our
antibiotics and everything are made in
China so we are dependent on them too
this is a symbiotic relationship that's
crazy
and to be that dependent on on a country
that owns a great deal of you know our
infrastructure for that matter certainly
the kind of medicines that we gave it'll
wake people up
ability well whether it does or not I
really do believe it's going to change
our our our relationship with China and
I think China is going to pay for it and
they don't they don't like that
how about drug colleges Chinese virus
well but also that bit everyone's upset
it did start there it's okay I'm sorry
that we no I don't think that's a tell
I understand why that's a bad thing we
don't want Chinese people in this
country to be you know discriminated
against it did start in China and a lot
of it was because so did SARS and a lot
of it's because of these wet markets
from what I understand and from other
cultural herpes so and in China goes out
and says that these war games that the
Americans are playing brought it to
China welcome now come on he's being bat
soup and should be sucking on their
noses
I heard they removed like credentials
for New York Times and a bunch of
different big you're doing the truth
that that's why that's why we don't know
how bad it got over there they don't
give us the real number we don't know if
it was horrific or if it's doing great
now China has accused you and I say some
particular racism for trying to label
the virus Chinese or Wuhan I mean that's
we started if it's our New York they're
called the New York virus yeah it's
created real tension with the Chinese
and I'm on America side of America
because American so you know I joined
China has Toby take some responsibility
for whatever is going on where there
where these kinds of things are being
bred I'm also stop eating bats I'm so
much food out there yeah green the Beth
I like a nice bag dude the cutemon
and that's probably sweet probably let's
not eat Pat's you don't need that suit a
bats carry a lot of that stuff I think
yeah I think you bats get that merge
scape gave Merce two camels in the
Middle East also bat bats or rats with
wings you can't eat you can't make baked
rat soup you know they think we bola
Marburg a lot of these [ __ ] things
come from bats
dude look at his foot look at that [ __ ]
leader look at her she's repeating that
bat I thought a lot of this was hype no
they they you don't [ __ ] nose first
and [ __ ]
so this sudden you look like a poor
thing looks like just like an exotic
thing I mean it's a thing I think oh
this might be exotic yeah you know I
don't think everybody eats bats
I don't know but bullfrogs and things
like that are definitely eating in China
look a lot of times a lot of this comes
in the history of China where people
didn't have a lot to eat and there was
you you had to eat what you could eat so
you're sweet that thing looks that's a
fruit bat that's a giant fruit bat if
I'm if I'm correct and fruit bats are
the ones that carry the Marburg virus
etc so we also practice Britain so my
guess is they don't need the actual bat
they just do dude look at this [ __ ] man
they're hot they're chewing on it here
but I mean it looks like the broth is
with what they're after more I guess you
might be biting the wing is it good what
do you think you man no she's I don't
know who knows but I did hear about bat
soup soup oh yeah who would even a
little bad dude they're so cute yeah
this one's cute till you break out with
Marburg and you have a hemorrhage and
look at them they're super cute he's a
really kid he's blind that isn't he bats
are bats here apparently some bats can
hear you smile I mean they can swallow a
mile away I don't believe what I heard
that I can hear you there their ears are
crazy
that's [ __ ] that they can hear
somebody swallow a mile away what
[ __ ] that's another thing that I was
told of my mom when I was a little kid
and I kept it in my brain echolocation
his mom's [ __ ]
dude I I keep things in my brain I was
thinking about the things that I keep my
brains I think about you know what I I
think it was one of the most traumatic
experiences of my life and I was
thinking about this we got molested no
not at all good time um I was in Lebanon
during the war and we were my dad
couldn't get back in the country and we
were living the holiday end we had to
sleep on the floor they'll wake up here
gorgeous I would hear machine guns but I
remember driving by a checkpoint and my
mother said there were these men who are
who are in a sort of a armoured car and
they had a machine gun and maybe it was
a Jeep and my mother when I was a little
kid said Brian don't look at those men
just keep your eyes ahead say yeah I
think about that every day and have
every day since that happened when I was
pretty six or seven yeah yeah I was
actually probably eight I remember that
so well and I was that yesterday I went
I I literally went I've been thinking
about that moment my whole [ __ ] life
and I read it in your mind yeah and it
informs I I remember feeling very
powerless and and most importantly I
couldn't protect my mom because they
were men with guns and I never forgot
that
and I spent six months you know in in
Lebanon like she knows I said war-torn
Lebanon yeah Jesus gray but they here I
saw a missile I saw planes bomb a gas
station right outside my window
I saw all kinds of crazy [ __ ] but I
would hear the machine gun to America
well he does his thing
well my dad was in I have probably
Greece or somewhere safe he couldn't get
back in and then and then we we got
evacuated to Greece I remember the word
evacuated a lot of all of everybody knew
it was evacuated range yeah so the
school's Creole teacher then I went back
in 1981 and I think was 81 after the
Israelis had invaded and I didn't
recognize anything in my childhood
because everything was smooth I never
forgot that then that was it crazy in
Lebanon was I it is a beautiful place is
it we do you remember traumatic things
yeah do you have any traumatic things
chin but I don't think of mr. attic
until I tell you you know where can I go
oh that built this it forms a lot of my
behavior so doing your [ __ ] kongfu
oh you do well first of all it's
pronounced point fool you had I find out
you have to say decline no Taekwondo
she can blow you [ __ ] do you have any
traumatic stay with you chin when I was
a little kid I'm more like when I was in
like growing up here just getting jumped
a lot really yeah agent well I mean also
I was running around like your friends
kind of dress kind of you know we wanted
to address cool and that cool now like
dressing sort of gangster sure sabi get
jumped often damn yeah that's it how
much each cat um just getting my ass
beat
my parents growing up oh that I think
that's completely hard yeah like the
last time I got beat by my parents I was
like 16
PVC pipe and I'd like to buy four block
that's too old to begin beat up yeah
although to be fair just let him do it
well yeah that's how you do things would
they hit down the back or you but no
they would make me lie on my stomach on
the bed almost like when you're getting
like arrested and your hands have to be
by your side and if you try to cover
your backside they would hit you more
and they would hit you harder and so you
have to just kind of like wait what did
you do as 16 to get hit with a pup my
dad found my boyfriend in my bed
we were like [ __ ] around and he came
in to use the printer and like my
boyfriend would try to like just stay as
still as possible but I think my dad saw
underneath my bed was his backpack and
his [ __ ] and so like he opened up the
covers and found him it was he very good
uh boxers boxers yes I think boxers and
then your dad beat the [ __ ] out of you
yeah well you know I'm reading a book
now called raising lions it's called the
art of compassionate discipline and
having children as they develop one of
the things that I never made sense to me
and it was indoctrinate was was I was
taught as a parent by certain
psychiatrists and people and
developmental educate you learned these
things was that you should never punish
your child you should reason with them
about why their behavior is Lad and then
listen and then you and then you praise
their good behavior now I instinctively
never saw that as making sense because
every culture that I know doesn't do
that except for California American new
aged rich psychology rich culture I come
from an Italian Irish background where
that was not the case where wooden
spoons belts and my dad size 14 shoe
wear I'm always a threat Bigfoot
and suddenly I was being told to raise
my kids
and my son went to a Montessori School
my son was a [ __ ] when he was younger
because he was just a strong-willed
child who had a great imagination so
what he would do is he would [ __ ] up
your work or just he liked disrupting
the class because he's like a showman he
likes the attention what they would do
is never ever scold him they said we
don't scold him we just
take his hand we just show him there's a
better way we talk to him I go that's
not working so I pulled him out of that
[ __ ] school because I don't believe
in that long story short I'm reading a
book called raising lions and the guy
said hold it this idea that children can
be reasoned with
that children don't need boundaries that
children are should be validated no
matter what they do praised for
everything instead of praise
specifically that children shouldn't be
disciplined with consequences when
they're crazy what happens when you
don't discipline a child when you don't
create consequences for a child is what
they do is they go you know what my will
is stronger than everybody's I'm more
powerful if I cause a scene they
capitulate and then what happens is they
feel that they feel their anxiety levels
go through the roof because they realize
that they are the ultimate power source
so they don't have boundaries so they go
I'm a bit it's a bit that's a form of
abandonment and so when you create
boundaries so this guy will take the
worst most and and so check that past 10
years the cases for labeling somebody
bipolar which really means your kid
flies off the handle has a tantrum is
uncontrollable they put you on four
different kinds of medication and that
the cases of childhood bipolar disorder
have increased 40 fold in the past ten
years and it's [ __ ] and these
psychiatrists they alternatives Medicaid
Medicaid or Medicaid get the [ __ ] and
I've been around this everybody wants to
medicate your child instead of realizing
and this [ __ ] comes in this guy
Newman is amazing it's called raising
lines he comes in and he took this kid
it was impossible to control freaking
out baby and they wanted to put him on
an anticonvulsant medication and this
other thing and he goes hold it because
now what I'm gonna have to do with this
kids I'm gonna have to hold him I'm
gonna have to restrain him every time he
freaks out and punches the kid and he
was big and strong and punched the kid
or whatever I'm gonna take him and give
him a timeout and when he resists the
timeout I'm gonna have to restrain him
I'm gonna have to hold them until he
freaks stops freaking out and then we're
gonna he did this for five days and that
teacher was like you gotta stop he's
freaking out freaked out for an hour
[ __ ] you cursing spitting trying to
headbutt him like you just held him
there sure held him there
took an hour next day 45 minutes next
day 25 minutes fine defect the end of
the day the kids started to realize yeah
or how about this when kids are they
don't focus and they disrupt the class
and they think well it might be bipolar
spectrum disorder they go hold it he is
smart enough to know that he's creating
frustration and adults I'm gonna make it
so it's frustrating for him so he'd go
oh you didn't you didn't you didn't
finish your homework cuz you're [ __ ]
around they're all off to recess you got
to stay and do your reason you got to
finish your homework that's what kid
went yeah yes homework tonight okay yeah
so what kids have to realize is that yes
they should have their own autonomy and
be able to express themselves but but
after me we put a great deal of and
we've put all he's used this distinction
he goes kids they have been all of their
all of the emphasis has been on
self-expression not self-discipline you
need both kids have to realize that the
adult in the room and other people there
will their desires their needs are just
as important as yours yes otherwise you
become an [ __ ] you become a
narcissistic [ __ ] and we've created
not only a [ __ ] generation of little
[ __ ] but also kids who anxiety
depression bipolar quote-unquote
disorder because they they just what's
this guy say about hitting your kids so
so hitting isn't as effective you don't
need to hit your yes what he would tell
you is you don't need to hit your kids
you give a kid a timeout where that kid
doesn't get to do anything but sit on a
stair and has to wait or stand and just
wait until you know the adults are ready
to have him back get engaged again he'll
learn really quickly that's not pleasant
yeah that sucks and so it was so good to
read a book like that because my
instincts were right I need that book
dude oh it's called raising Lions cry I
think Joe Newman I can't recommend it
highly enough do you have in your car uh
no yes I do but I got I got uh I'm
almost done it's [ __ ] great it's
called raising lions and and it's it's
so interesting man and it's it's it's
exactly house right now you don't want
it you don't want to have an
authoritarian parent will you just get
hit and you have no ability to express
your creativity you don't be scared upin
yeah but you also wanna ruin lives
back respect but you also you know I'm
around kids all the time you'll see
parents that are like there they don't
dis plan all their more friends yeah
with the kid and those kids they're so
bad oh yeah oh yeah there's a group of
my kid doesn't play with them because
the kids are so bad right and those kids
can be fixed like instead of saying to
like a lot of parents do this too they
they go up they main take a look at that
you made her cry isn't that it now now
don't you feel bad you made her cry
what's wrong with you and what happens
is the kid goes well I don't feel bad
you're making me feel guilty and ashamed
because I didn't think of it and he's
not kids are not that sophisticated with
you you have to say you have to say so
so now you have now you have a timeout
because you didn't you didn't you
disrupt the things that made that person
feel bad and that's what happens yeah or
when you praise people say everything
you do is great no no no there's nothing
wrong with being first of all when
someone a kid doesn't do such a good job
you go you know what I feel like you
could have done better or when you
praise praise specifically like that's
the best painting ever instead of that
go I like some of the colors you used
now that makes it really pleasant to
look at if you if you're so good at
anything ever come on right and people
do that though on and so you give the
kid a false sense of reality or the
other problem is that when when the kid
is being raised by parents that are
really weak but then they come to school
with more discipline they rebelled oh
right
I'll tell you what interesting in LA the
the governor just said there won't be
any school to a September Wow
listen with with a four year old that is
a nice wish for my girl you know I still
got it work with you at home my nice my
eight-year-old start crazy go crazy this
is my son has so much energy he wants to
do a million things yeah just usually
give it out at school but then you don't
have that it is a bit but bucolic -
clothes are later clothes remain great
that's crazy
come on man come on it's better to be
safe than sorry though right I don't
know don't that's it that's a little
extreme well one can't afford child care
I know that's a major problem for them I
mean it's a major problem wait guys
newson gonna give them money and plus
they're probably losing jobs too I know
peep
they're in real trouble already and
every day without jobs and they don't
think they work in the service industry
they don't have any money
yeah that's [ __ ] the CDC improv [ __ ]
though a great DC improv shut up you
mean shut down
I mean DC improv [ __ ] every not
permanently closed yeah well I don't
know don't go to their Instagram well
all of its shut down everywhere I I
don't mean like that I mean they're
closed bright like fired all the
employees everybody Wow laid off
employees we have been overwhelmed by
people now going to them go to the one
before this go to that one the last two
weeks have been a nightmare with the
last two days putting in the nail in the
coffin here's other side to the
quarantine today at the layoffs almost
my entire staff 50 people the world's
have been rocked and lives are forever
changed the DC improv is closed for who
knows how long I have no idea if my
business will be able to weather this
storm and reopen I have to had make some
most difficult decisions in my life all
while trying to keep it together handle
the anxiety of our customer and staff
I've never been so sad in my life I do I
cannot help as I try to salvage the
business I devoted close to 22 years I'm
grateful to community to perform at the
club a survivor been through a lot of my
life I will do whatever I can do to try
to get through this with the goal of
getting my crew back together again this
has been devastating horrible yeah great
[ __ ] Club great club in there forever
man you here's what else you so you know
these DC they improv right there they're
nationwide The Improv czar owned to
under a banner but mom-and-pop ones like
wise guys and you tall you can't do
anything different animal yeah they have
nuts
you know they've they've bills to pay I
can't do anything but they're probably
there's the master improv and then
trickles down they're gonna be alright
but that's what I like that's why I
skies man
I find myself how long do you want to
shut this down cuz you're did this virus
is destroyed the economy don't have
money dobra it doesn't have money people
have money yeah you open these up
they're not big it's gonna take a while
before even people are buying tickets to
watch us be dumbass
it's why I really wonder how much is the
juice worth the squeeze what are we
doing here
yeah it's contagious yeah people are
gonna die so we got a but how long do
you want to do this for until you can do
for the rest of the year now dude this
stimulus package that Trump is gonna
send the Fed and everybody there they're
coming into this is when you need the
Fed this is when you need a stimulus
package it's a $3,000 Wow okay good luck
with that
cuz I got my coke habit I got yeah yeah
bye shoes well I want to do drugs they
give me 1000 I've been drinking that
night I've been drinking whiskey I've
been drinking good sake I I just find
myself watching that awesome show flea
bag I'm upset with it it's so you know I
got into I can't drink it homey works I
made a promise to my family but I still
do stuff I mean you have had that's the
dude that's a that's a week old and
they're sending us ten more bottles it's
my birthday drink so I watched this
documentary on Netflix called cue cue
ball it's about prison inmates in a
north northern Francisco jail prison
sorry prison San Francisco prison and
some more pretty good man some are
[ __ ] cute the letter Q ball how do
you type in Q cuz there it is but
they're just what are you doing throwing
up you throw up why spit it up I was
weird but this Q ball I mean you talk
about some guys some serious convictions
one guy you know good this guy here the
Division one ball player yeah and here's
what's cool about this is they have
volunteers come every weekend so their
season just volunteers I play like in a
league Reckling they come to the prison
to play them and but then also at the
end of the year the winners of the their
league get to play against to go on
state warriors cuz I salt the Warriors
so if I get to go and state were close
so they had Kevin Garnett there last
time and a interview time they go hey
any of these guys can even play
professional and he's pointing to that
that guy they showed Duncan there like
that that number 11
I could probably do something special
really well you know I he went to prison
well he haven't finished it but I think
he's in for seven years he was up for
seven years because he was a kind of a
pimp and he was working out uh he was
working at a strip club and he got
arguing with his girl and she had his
key or wall in her purse and he wanted
to give him away from she started acting
all wild and he pushed her down and
grabbed him out seven years because he
pushed her down that's his story I feel
like he's lying to me in seven years and
there's one guy who's there I had prior
convictions for stuff yeah that's one
guy he's pretty good he's all old I
figure what they call that the good guys
name ATL but there's what yeah there's a
deal but there's one guys older they go
how long you in for well he sent for 105
years to life another guy no yeah you
might remember this guy he's at a I
think a Dodge or a Giants game he's at
Giants game he's with his boys just the
coach of the team that's guy who in for
190 years but he's the coach of the team
right so he's and he's kind of younger I
think he's in for life but he he's
getting out and Perl but he was at a San
Francisco Giants game he's with his boys
in his car the game got out and they're
trying to drive you know and the game
got out and then a group of family you
know they're trying to walk and he's in
the crosswalk the kid hits the hood it's
like it's dude we're [ __ ] walking
he's drunk you know kid well the guy
felt embarrassed because he did to his
car knees with his boys the gang members
whenever so he gets out in his word you
say dude and they start arguing the guys
like down to do it so they start
fighting right he started for break him
up he gets out a knife he says and I
finally get loose and he goes and I just
stabbed the guy five times stem in the
heart stem of the heart cut off the
bottom of his heart where the aura is
that sure and he said he started crying
cause he said he looked at the eye and
the guy's like what what the [ __ ] kid
he goes I could tell you he didn't know
what to do because he was he was dying
and he was like trying to like do
something this when you cut the heart
there's nothing and then they show the
mom and she's just like man I don't
think he should ever get out my son's
never gonna be able to get married or do
things for this [ __ ] yeah that's
one of those I have a lot of sympathy
for inmates when I
your stories because I feel like you at
a moment in your life that you [ __ ] up
and you took someone's life
and I understand how the victims family
feels of course but I find myself going
you probably overall were a good guy who
made a terrible mistake in that your own
angry man and your whole life is gone
you know who's fat another fascinating
one on there if you're bored in
quarantine right now you watch shows to
watch Unabomber there's a four part
suicide bomber this dude you know he
went to Harvard
Oh smartest yo Harvard was like dude
[ __ ] was a great math aims are an
amazing mathematician amazing
self-taught learn how to make the bombs
his brother cuz I don't know where he
went wrong everything was all good and
then and then his younger brother goes I
remember I brother got back from Harvard
and the heõs and I read all these books
and all these theories and he was I was
excited to see him is to tell my
knowledge and some of my theories of my
ideas of the world and I give him the
ideas and he shot him down like nasty
like shot em all down saying oh it's all
part of the [ __ ] you're in though
you're a rat and the cycle and he's a
current the [ __ ] and he said the
smartest minds the geniuses all have a
sinister a sinister path yeah he says
little brothers like what the [ __ ] you
Tom might do you went to Harvard being
crazy and then just he thought you know
he hated the Machine yeah for dude he
was on the loose for ever man you know I
wonder if some of this stuff is the fact
that he couldn't get laid that somebody
broke his heart that somebody humiliated
him you know are these men like like
kind of like an in cell you know one of
those guys who was like oh [ __ ] I can't
get laid nobody wants me I'm gonna blow
people up dude who's a professor at Cal
well I think he was a runner-up for the
Fields Medal of mathematics or something
crazy like literally and like um
youngest as he became the youngest
assistant professor of mathematics in
the history of University of California
Berkeley Wow Wow his teaching evaluation
suggests he was not well-liked by a
students of course seen an uncomfortable
teacher just straight from the book out
of all the [ __ ] he did this is terrible
still three too many but it only killed
three people he injured a lot
with bombs wasn't a great bomb maker but
out of all the shitty do the only kill
he put a bomb on the plane
ah and it blew up was just wasn't strong
enough
yeah piece of [ __ ] Oh piece of completed
piece of [ __ ] yeah he was a very bad
well whatever happened to him he's just
probably a sociopath nothing was
changing the the machine as they call it
change the machine by any means
necessary
yeah through violence yeah well he was
the one I think who was also talking
about stopping technology because human
beings are going to create machines yep
he that are gonna hate technology hate
hates a humanity there we're gonna
create machines that are smarter than we
are and have no respect for us and then
kill us
which crazy is like he would have this
journal where he wrote in code just
numbers you got this like they they
found somebody to decipher the numbers
and then it was his journal of these
bombs and what he wanted to do in his
plans but it's all coded in numbers it's
not the dude was wicked smart knock just
a psychopath
you know the key lived in a cabin no
electricity no running water you want
what if we go back swimmin we're like
hey come over for a party and just a
bunch of like gals were there and were
like hey man I heard they blow some
thank you or he'd just have a girlfriend
and she'd be like ah he's crazy but he's
cool wonder how much does he need to be
validated get to his dick and his tummy
want some dinner and a dicksuck uh yeah
the saw the computer store owner Hugh
you blew him up in Sacramento so he died
and then his last two he finally got
better at making mom's what he just so
lose her man
yeah just a lost loser why don't you
turn that kid like this thing but they
get there not him they're nothing you
know if I'm not smart enough no you get
a real wicked smart one like this got
problems I mean even the team for
everyone pull it off was his plan for
Destruction killed three people yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and your dumb little
cash be dumb now
you enjoy that [ __ ] cabin jacking off
to the [ __ ] beavers yeah
stay angry
CEL yeah I mean if there is Armageddon
the first thing you got to do is
probably bomb to kill all the bad guys I
mean you got to go into jail remember in
Game of Thrones when they knew that
there was going to be that they were
gonna be invaded and that there was
gonna be can war and the guy said he
didn't they just went into the jails and
killed all the murderers and people and
and the robber and they want him getting
out yeah because once they get out it
makes it even worse and when so I'm
saying let all the prisoners out of Iraq
he let over emptied the jails so all
those bad people kind of get out and
started doing crazy [ __ ] if you we let
if we let everybody out of jails chaos
oh my god yeah people getting jacked in
the street raped everything if you let
everybody out most of the people in jail
are not bad people most of my own drug
offenses and on my own it just [ __ ] up
if you let the drugs I sent that live in
they're the ones in for assault and
felony like real felonies now but
besides drug-related let them out
they'll team up no just bad [ __ ] got to
go in there and be like mm you're
anybody who touch kids anybody the
[ __ ] you know murdered and raped
anybody serial thief we gotta get we
gotta get rid of you gotta get rid of
you how would you kill him Hugh man that
[ __ ] him in firing squad yeah just not
just in their cell you just do it very
when they're sleeping or song I don't
want to torture anybody you just pop pop
pop pop silencer is that is that harsh
I'm with it I can't have him I can't let
them all out and then raping and killing
the people potatoes you know you know
like there's that there's a there's a
housing unit in Arizona that keeps all
the sexual offenders violent offenders
they can wear pretty stuff whatever they
do that that I got to drop a bomb on
that place I know there are some people
that might you know above all but no but
at the end of the day I can't have
sexual deviants free teaming up with
each other you guys all know each other
now I mean this is really harsh to say
but I think if it was the Armageddon and
I had a choice of letting them out
letting them under you got to [ __ ]
drop a bomb on that place and then
anybody on death row I'm sure there's
some innocence but overall my guess is
you're on death row for a bad reason
you're a good reason you know I'm gonna
have your legs make an omelet I got hit
review that break a few I need a gangly
like the big-time kingpins you got to
get out of here any of the hit men you
got to get out of here right I mean is
that I think you're right dude give some
curt events if you want the best
supplements on planet earth if you want
a home gym if you want an online
exercise program we got you covered with
on it if you want kettlebells if you
want chimp bells if you want gorilla
bells me if you want Star Wars mm-hmm if
you want battle room if you want food I
don't know elk bars when you're playing
we're hunting if you want about the [ __ ]
yeah coffee dude keep emphasizing it on
it
black rifle the two best of the best
decided to do a coffee and it has
caffeine crystals in it you know me dude
I'm one step away from trying meth in my
veins because coffee doesn't work
anymore but [ __ ] yeah coffee does it
gets me raring to go and you get 10% off
go to audit comm slash fighter for 10%
off everything MCT oil the almonds the
best of my face on it
they got freaking fat butter elk bars
Omega protein bars warrior bars joint
oil MCT oh I've already said that twice
now it's that goddamn good [ __ ] yeah
coffee black rifle on it on it calm
slash fighter for 10% off the entire
damn website all right you guys ready
yeah all right first one okay so a
teenage student in the UK was suspended
from school last week because he was
charging students I think it was like a
couple of what's their currency like
pennies like couple of like their
version of his sons pounds or euro
couple quid yeah I think it's probably
quid he was charging students for a pump
of hand sanitizer
yeah entrepreneur and he got suspended
for it when his mom when his mom found
out she tried to punish him and she says
I it was really hard considering that
the dad was texting him saying that he
was a [ __ ] legend sixty-five cents
for a [ __ ] man I love this kid and
the mom also came out and said that he
didn't make too much
money off of it her son was just really
excited to be able to buy a kebab after
school oh are you got it alone man he's
awesome
come on he's a capitalist I like him
that's cool good for you you [ __ ]
legend
we said we we support you we support you
[ __ ] legend son okay Oh
pornhub has announced that there is a
huge spike in views and they actually
also have this program where they're
allowing people in Italy to use pornhub
premium for free for the rest of the
month yeah and there has been a huge
spike in views in Italy how about how
have you know I am watched where C's all
are done here have you watched porn you
don't know I don't I just not done I
don't even think about it
I'll think about it but not a ton no but
a lot of people watch it I just it's
like this now I'm gonna now that you
watch it a lot I might watch it tonight
I don't watch as much anymore yeah yeah
you got a girl yeah a plus it just
changes your frickin body you used to
watch it a lot
it changes your body like you know we'd
have a girlfriend you gonna you're gonna
jack off on your own for sure all right
yeah and then you're gonna watch porn
yeah but then I like then your your
brain is like adjust to porn as a
turn-on sweer
I know they got Jane there choke on it
well Jesus Christ mate you mind my
friend comes over huh oh is it a pizza
man Oh what's this you know you're in
prison for rape
and hungry yeah pornos [ __ ] things
out dude
girl Z I compete with that [ __ ] look at
that look at the spike in March yeah
March third fourth fifth a day that
people were talking about potentially
quarantine is when the views just went
through the roof crazy is that look at
that and apparently there's a lot of
searches for coronavirus on there too
like a lot of people are specifically
littler coronavirus part people are so
weird
that's funny what else you got alright
I think it's this one here joining the
mic on doing podcasting way too long so
jared leto
was on [ __ ] yeah i seated meditation
retreat for the past 12 days he was
recently let out and there were no cell
phones no sort of connection to the
outside world in this retreat and he
came back he said that he came back to
the worst possible outcome more la dude
be more la in every way journalist Wow
12 days ago being a silent meditation in
the desert
we were totally isolated no phones no
communication etc we had no idea what
was happening outside the facility
walked out yes into a very different
world one that's been changed forever
mine wouldn't say the least I'm getting
message from friends and family all
around the globe catching up on what's
going on hope you and yours are okay sin
and positive energy stay inside stay
safe okay first of all no it hasn't been
changed forever
okay you [ __ ] be more la dude your
silent meditation with your [ __ ] butt
would be costume no but he's gone he's
like yeah that felt good man what the
[ __ ] you come back that guy and just
last week he was talking about almost
dying while he was rock climbing went
automated yeah you didn't know what that
was in 12 days ago he said that the rock
climbing happened like a couple of days
or like a week or so before he's got a
picture of himself
yeah like and it says stay safe thanks
for the picture of you too thanks for
the inspiration [ __ ] I would never
hang out with that [ __ ] guy oh I
would I wouldn't hang out at that Tim
cried with a ball now I play
this guy's [ __ ] the brave whoa dude
halt - he's brave - dealt with a drone
dude ah damn we're drunk that's deep
it's hard to defend that how about but
so you know here his team sat around as
a dude let's I'm gonna climb this bridge
let's get some cool footage we're gonna
get a drone that's a whole thing there
that 15 me clip is a 15 second clip is
all whole day's worth of shooting well
there's a lot that one that's not like
oh let me climbs dude dude selfie click
and move on with your life that that
they plan that oh and at the end of it
ha there's nothing trying to make me
look cool well they had nothing to do
there nothing Vanity's see what else he
has on there and again I'm still a fan
let me see him singing in there
is neat fifty years old just that beer
de stop where he is not worried about
Corona
his voice is derivative it's there I
said it
dude you just quit hating oh my god his
voice Wow
lassie I rock the role of yeah [ __ ] off
what's this one not a fan
never have been never will be it's like
a tick-tock thing mm-hmm cool I have no
words also tempted to thin maybe one
more one more
yeah he's very happy when you're my
selfies please there is so official
selfies up yeah very happy as a chick
he's almost hot chicks very happy to
himself look in my eyes you're killing
me killing me I still remember the
moment I wrote that song on the tour bus
driving across America talk about life
changing deep [ __ ]
very always yeah dude let me see more of
the video well this one's gonna be a
bummer
you want someone deaq it's just him with
a tick-tock filters yeah he's just happy
with himself my spiked Gucci like him
that there's a lot of selfies and he's
it's a lot of his face yeah yeah let's
see him there was I keep going to so
vain
he's so vain he is a gorgeous he's he's
he's a [ __ ] zero up dude yeah I said
it it's my birthday and what uh what
would I bring him up there he better be
very polite around me because there's
gonna be a toss-up well and I don't have
your hands full
keep going what did you send me he did
as much like Lana ji just shut the [ __ ]
up
don't ever say I'd had my hands that
that's tough dude yes all right huh that
was tough
yeah he is so happy with himself never
he doesn't [ __ ] hot chicks at all keep
going ever look your tits
I'll [ __ ] him how's that sound whoa look
at that one yeah Fight Club cool those
aren't real tattoos no that's right okay
good let me see another video could this
one happier with him sure
he couldn't be happy or the miss once
his best friend is his haircut is his
hair long arthritis on the knuckle right
here
his hair is falling out oh my god I mean
this is the ugliest tree I've ever seen
in my entire life
we'll take it I was a bargain let it
snow let it snow it's very weird
I don't always try to do I don't like
him
give me one more video cooking give me
that bottle
this is Brennan's hero to this no no no
it's in my hair oh well I'm a fan of his
movies and music bottom right this guy
yeah let's see
oops I think it's just a music major
bust rotation whatever you want bug guys
this is the colony is like a little
fungus vodka it felt like Billy Bob door
handle it off it's very bizarre and no
more your favorite person boy that's a -
keep goin - terrible Instagram page yeah
he's tearing because he's terrible oh
there is what the Sun I'm in with that
guy though hey did you see a [ __ ] simple
I'm in El Cap over this yeah did you see
yeah hilarious
Tai Lopez Nora Tai Lopez you know I got
the book guy yeah take take a look at
him now do you die take your life dude
pass away yeah I was think people died
10 billion dollar giveaway go look at
Stewart Oh what the hell yeah it's 204
pounds I'd stay furloughed there's no
way huh sometimes you're bored sometimes
you know whatever message you're pushing
is not going well so you need something
to do so you inject a [ __ ] ton of
steroids in your body it looks like
Ludacris from that music video let's see
let's see their body Susie this one yeah
let's see yes say Zak who should I give
this $10,000 to me always me don't
follow everybody I follow even wait ten
thousand dollars this month follow
everybody that I'm following on
Instagram and pick two winners a day
five hundred bucks each you can't
Wow Wow I don't know
there you go it's the life stop Oh boys
okay
what is back up our chest is 48 that's
awesome bro his body looked a little odd
too right
I thought it looked that way better one
is good yeah yeah like right there he
looks long you know the-- i liked your
little better what else you got
I don't know he's doing it I'll write a
book to promote it our Vanessa Hudgens
is getting some who is she
backlash right now she's in high school
musical can't wait to hear what she has
to say
she says she was talking about
coronavirus and people didn't like what
she said so I'll play for them because I
mean yeah till July it sounds like a
bunch of bull I'm sorry but like when
she talks a virus I got it like I
respect it but at the same time like
even if everybody gets it
like yeah just terrible but like
inevitable so I was like Instagram live
and there she saw has since apologized
well okay I don't care about her so it
doesn't hey guys so I flew everyone I
raise my words were insensitive and that
was all appropriate for the situation
our country in the world
right now this has been a huge wake-up
call about significant more than ever
I'm feel I'm sending safe wishes to
everyone to stay safe and healthy I'm
like seven-shape was just everyone like
stay safe like multi and like crazy time
who gives a [ __ ] about actors I am a
[ __ ] people are so bored to get on
these Instagram lives and just like if
we don't need it I will say that's so
entertaining to see how stupid certain
people are cuz they're so bored and
doing these Instagram live videos yeah
it's gonna embarrass me this is a very
awkward so do you know the W
how to do a closed event with no
audience so imagine them doing their
yeah oh my god I can't wait for this
John Cena looks a little bit like Mark
Wahlberg let me play this clip oh yes a
giant version of Mark Wahlberg you wanna
know what Mark Wahlberg would look like
if he's huge
let me refresh this page oh my god
there's no audience and that's the Iowas
is very fun to watch and a very cringy
way thoughts on this segment two empty
aliens I started listening to them the
stuffs already good and they took my
crooked little world and they turned it
into a majestic funhouse rocked me John
but you fiend
the boys the exact father yeah and at
WrestleMania it's going to be a
slaughter you just don't know it yet
oh my god I'm surprised they're not
laughing oh they'll be so hard to not
wanna start laughing here though at the
end oh my god that's great so so awkward
press you and I tried nope nope I don't
want yelling you right now don't want it
well we have more of an audience when I
come at you for surf and turf whether
you bring the turf or the third or the
sir I will be fighting you with every
inch of my and the missus let me Lee
fighting will pure American human will
[Music]
if I just send you 74 just shut the
event down man
cha god damn Iran Enter the Dragon when
bolo would get them to fight and the
command was da bowl of nut yeah yeah
yeah
sheesh how badass is bolo especially
back then a great way yeah easy to be
that buff back then yeah he [ __ ] huge
his sons huge - what's this now I'm sure
you heard of this already
he sounds [ __ ] this game plot
strategy and this is this really is you
guys are talking about support but this
really is a girl who's trying to be
super famous so we're giving her a
little bit of attention up but she is
doing a coronavirus challenge where
she's looking at oh let's eat in an
airplane no she goes yeah besides
somebody's done she was on dr. Phil to
you Oh about trying trying to get like
followers what happened probably like
dr. Phil like do ya sanitize the [ __ ]
out of course oh did she say that no but
of course she's not gonna do it it's
probably wrap it still freaking it's
just it's just embarrassing to evening
doing that even if it was sanitized you
ever see the movie Trainspotting an old
movie he's a junkie
and he goes to ask her the bathroom so
badly because when you when you do
opioids when you do heroin you get
constipated for 18 days oh and then when
you have to [ __ ] and he's gone and he
breaks in and this time is the worst
toilet in Scotland bring that oh you
McGregor yeah if you and Greg this is
one of the greatest movies ever it broke
all the [ __ ] mold it was nobody was
making movies like this this was genius
when it came out yeah here you go here
you go look at his the worst toilet ever
in the worst toilet in Scotland want a
[ __ ] hit he does such a good job as a
heroin addict in this this is about the
heroin industry in Scotland the whole
heroin the world he's wearing tight
pants putting him right up his ass oh
you got a [ __ ] dude just [ __ ] on the
floor dude yes Oh God I really had to
[ __ ] though taking lots out yeah you can
tell sick already he's what throw the
client he falls into it and he swims in
it and comes out looking this mind it's
a great movie though [ __ ] great movie
funny um let's do this one cuz the big
news Tom Brady oh my god
during the tampa bay buccaneers come to
LA Chargers hmm what why why Tampa they
just paid in the most what I think you
went there they got a lot they got a
good you know they got a good squad
pretty easy conference he doesn't have
to deal with Patrick mahomes so they get
to the Super Bowl
so there's that you know if you would
went to the Chargers just playing
Patrick mahomes twice a year and then
again in the playoffs so three times a
year at least you know you want a void
Patrick really yeah that good oh yeah
the best so I think just about
Buccaneers they're loaded good defense
you know is that good money thirty
million a year for Tom Brady let's see
it's good money I mean I don't think
she's trying to be the highest-paid you
know but you got 30 million not bad
alrighty
yeah be exciting though yeah they're
saying season tickets for Tampa Bay went
through the roof slaps fight it yeah
this is a pretty crazy video and so
there's this dude who's a brother I
guess his mom or his mother-in-law was
inside the plane as well and then he was
complaining that two guys are elbowing
her the stewardesses and then this is
what ensued afterwards
and watch this this is where it gets
crazy
so there's a female stewardess watch
this right here right here watch this
[Music]
right here right here
[Music]
boys are bland but you see the
stewardess slapped him first
yeah well she was spitting in fact he
was spitting on his luck [ __ ] that guy
but today what the boys jumped on him
sir whooping is that what had done that
to the girl filming was witness no
that's an older lady she slaps you take
the take to slap don't slap her back you
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that guy that gets me
angry I know everything changed this
guy's being a [ __ ] idiot screaming
about what what happened what did what
happened with him his mother or mother
or mother his mother-in-law
okay sitting in a seat and he was saying
to guys beside her were just elbowing I
would come on so he wanted to complain
to the people he's defending her mother
yeah but a lot but apparently he was
like too aggressive so they started
going to him like to calm him down
sure and then this ensued yeah well he
he's got problems yeah definitely is way
too angry and maybe maybe mom has
problems and maybe everything is a
little crazy
he sounds like he's crazy what's funny
is she slapped him the men who jumped
autumn broke his ribs and then the
police drugged him down the plain steel
stairs oh really
it's a girl man police struck him down
this place what'd you get dude yeah
that's fine he deserved yeah that's what
I'm saying I mean awful knocking a
little bit you can't hit a lady
yeah he's smash he's hit her hard we'll
go with the open hand but hit her hard
yeah [ __ ] you and she still stood she
wasn't crying or anything a tough German
woman or whatever just from Brussels all
right what else yep this is cool
part of New approved cb8 oh that's no
longer suspend to positive marijuana
it's it's really cool and the MBA it's
not drug testing right that's smoke
weight is usually drug test NBA's like
now we're good yeah wait isn't it isn't
a performance enhancer
right it helps with the inflammation you
know brain yeah up like that so it's
late for them if there was like a NFL
player that also quit NFL because you
can smoke weed Enrique really yeah that
guy that's a big well he was really good
too though mental he just had
I think social anxiety he's a great
football player is almost 255 pounds can
run like yeah great football there's a
lot of guys you quit cuz of weed mmm
well they kept getting busted yeah Josh
Gordon I think he's doing other things
but weed especially [ __ ] them you know
who sada still testing USC fighters
throwing this rake it's so stupid
no just everything you draw the corona
stuff even now they're still coming
around interesting just trying to keep
the job you know um you want one more
sure this is a this is just everyone
sent this to me for Brian son I guess
she's Chinese bodybuilder her very much
I'm also a fan she's very buff she she's
the booty up he's doing very but I mean
honestly when I looked at these pictures
great ass some of them have been you
know photoshopped a bit yeah she's has
the greatest genetics her skin's gonna
be tough
there's some this and she's had a lot of
work done but see that that's they made
her wider here right there's no way that
could be I don't know but you look at
other things oh let's see her over there
let's see her which one that one of her
flex in the video pretty [ __ ] she's
pregnant what it's a skinny see I've
been pushing for two months see it looks
regular there right not for me
yeah not not really for me all right
well I'm impressed I don't like her
she'll have a huge dick well she's gonna
her booties got something to say he's
very strange there's stuff going on here
I'm yeah it doesn't look so good on her
the muscle that looks good that does
look good
I appreciate that first she's a very
athletic young lady
so yeah well that's cool affair in law
resting when you're playing with dog
there you go there it is that's a nice
leo let me hope you enjoy the view down
where your hips oh there you go all
right interesting I like her they're not
as cut yeah I don't like gonna see it's
all lean
well look at that yeah well
she's a strange one mm-hmm my pillow
crazy
oh she's batshit crazy mm-hmm great ass
I have to say the ass is on point that
seems pretty cool it's on point
good for her very impressive that's
pretty much it is it fair that a lot of
Chinese not you know a lot of asses
Vietnamese have asses but you know
you'll be nervous about defense but for
the most part Chinese are not known for
their bulbous asses that's fair either
Koreans yeah things tend to be a little
bit more on the [ __ ] so I have no ass
she's right there yeah no ass did your
girl have a boutique she doesn't have
she has she's tiny but she has big she
has big boobs are they real they're all
the things some Vietnamese women won't
have big butts but they'll have big
boobs yeah some not the end of the world
in the world man for me and it's a sin
but what happened flat asses are sin
right that's an easy fix a lot of white
guys that only mess with Asian girls of
course I love a lot of girls oh and
that's all white guys really yes cat no
she likes asian guys allocation guys
yeah I like white guys - yeah but well
good white guys an Asian guys and black
guys like you - I think guys like yeah
things like that that's very cute all
right kids said he'll give me your dates
just get it seasoned everybody stop
teasing everybody got a [ __ ] cancel
everything
all right guys love you rock with your
[ __ ] Carl happy birthday Brendan
interrupt will occur
and guess the funny kid Ralph a birthday
happy birthday